Do we know that there is a plant which
cannot directly absorb nitrogen from the soil but what it does for this is eat
insects. So yes, which
plant is yours? That is an insect
borer plant, which one is Venus?  It is a flight
trap, what does it do? Your
nectar glades
produce secretions which attract insects towards them
and as soon as the insect
comes to the leaf, their sensory hairs get activated and
what do they do
to the leaf?  They close it due to which your
insect gets trapped inside it
and it secretes some of your enzymes
due to which your insect will be
hydrolyzed and the plant
will get a rich source of nitrogen, so for such an
amazing fact, watch the channel.  Like and
subscribe thank you